[Music]
we love thanksgiving here at hillsdale
college
comes at a great time of year and we
have so much for which to be grateful
i've been thinking about that word
grateful gratitude and uh if you read
its story it's an old word
it turns out there are three parties
involved in gratitude
uh in the oxford english dictionary the
first definition is uh
pleasing or thankful
so pleasing how's that the same as
thankful
because if something is pleasing you'd
be grateful for it but that means
somebody else gave it to you
so
the attitude of gratitude connects you
with others
reminds you of what they do for you
helps your relations with them which are
of course fundamentals human happiness
and then of course you're involved too
because if you have a feeling of
gratitude
then you're looking outside yourself
and you see things that make you happy
and you're grateful for those and that
attitude makes you more open to things
makes you better able to see
makes you calmer
makes you more reverent
and reverence is the right attitude
toward the highest things
the third party involved is uh
not immediately visible and yet written
everywhere
we live in nature
the beauties of it surround us
the challenges of it
test us
we are of such a nature as to attempt to
meet those challenges
we are fitted into nature
we are somewhere in the order of nature
the order of nature
we didn't make that
capacities we didn't make them
they're given to us
by a maker the maker
and so to feel your life and see the
things around you
the people who do good for you
your gratitude to them
it connects you to your maker
and of course that's a divine thing and
that's the whole purpose of a college to
understand the order of nature and the
being that sits atop it
at hillsdale college we are having so
far a very happy thanksgiving
and we wish you one as well
[Music]
you